Найбільш ий транспортний літак світу Ан-225 "Мрія"
здіймається в повітря зі злітної смуги аеропорту держпідприємства "Антонов" в Гостомелі.
Літак рік не здійснював рейсів через роботи з модернізації.
І свій перший рейс тепер уже модернізована "Мрія" виконує до Китаю,
аби забрати вантаж для боротьби з пандемією коронавірусу і доставити його в ЄС.
Багатьом країнам світу нині потрібні сотні тисяч тонн захисних масок,
протиепідеміологічних костюмів, окулярів, дезінфекторів, апаратів ШВЛ тощо.
Тож, нині українські "Руслани" та "Мрія" стали найбільш затребуваними в світі вантажними літаками.
Те, що нині перевозить "Руслан", могли би возити й інші літаки.
Але обсяг вантажної кабіни АН-124 та АН-225 дозволяє одним рейсом привезти те,
чого не можуть привезти 5-6 "Боїнгів".
Треба наразі швидко доправляти ці вантажі до країн, де спалах коронавірусу.
Знаєте, як кажуть, дороге яєчко на Великдень.
У перевезеннях засобів захисту проти коронавірусу
беруть участь п'ять із семи українських "Русланів".
З 19 березня літаки вже встигли розвезти засоби захисту
від коронавірусу в майже три десятки країн.
Наразі у закордонних відрядженнях перебувають майже 200 "антонівських" пілотів та техніків.
Це приблизно 10 екіпажів.
Режим роботи в умовах пандемії коронавірусу пілоти називають "надзвичайним".
DW поспілкувалася з командиром та штурманом одного з екіпажів.
За час пандемії на своєму "Руслані" вони побували вже в США,
Німеччині, Португалії, Румунії, Катарі.
Важка дуже робота нашого інженерного складу.
Вони практично працюють на межі людських можливостей, тому що
завантаження, контроль завантаження, розвантаження.
Ви собі уявить: аеропорт Доха, висока температура, а ви працюєте в масці, рукавичках,
костюмі, окулярах, і треба виконувати ту ж саму роботу.
Це як психологічно важко, так і фізично важко.
Це ж не півгодини, а годинами буває...
Конструкція "Русланів" та "Мрії" передбачає,
що пілоти взагалі не контактують з технічним персоналом, навіть під час польоту.
Відповідно до нових санітарних правил,
під час розвантаження та завантаження льотчики теж не виходять з кабіни.
Пілоти зізнаються: складно звикнути до того,
що під час польоту в радіусі тисяч кілометрів - нікого, що в радіоефірі - тиша
і не чути перемовин інших екіпажів з диспетчерами.
Світова авіація фактично завмерла на тлі пандемії.
Це, з одного боку, пригнічує, каже командир "Руслана", а з іншого -
є і деякі позитивні моменти: пілоти принаймні не мають тепер звичного стресу в аеропортах
і рейси виконуються без запізнень.
Для пілотів нині немає стресів.
Уявіть собі, такий аеропорт, як Афіни, в якому черга на посадку, черга на виліт,
а зараз ніяких черг немає.
Зайшов - сів. Коли треба - то вирулив-вилетів. Як для пілотів, то стало все значно простіше.
Ще місяць тому в аеропортах було не протовпитися.
Нині - пусті зали, коридори, стійки, біля яких нікого немає.
Лише українські пілоти, співробітники аеропорту та лікарі,
які постійно перевіряють температуру членів екіпажу, потім дезінфікують їх і їхні валізи.
Нові умови роботи через коронавірус асоціюються для пілотів насамперед
зі стійким запахом дезінфекції.
У готелі на кожному місці: на вході, на ресепшен,
біля номерів, ліфтів стоять пляшки з рідиною, де теж можна обробити руки.
Миємо руки. Ці постійні процедури присутні в нашому житті.
Навіть сніданок у готелі ми отримуємо запакованим, укритий, закритий.
Усе окремо розкладено.
Людина приносить нам у спецільному одязі.
І ми так само намагаємося вживати це все дуже обережно. Кожну ложечку вимиваєш,
щоб забезпечити якусь безпеку для себе.
Авіакомпанія "Авіалінії Антонова" намагається максимально подбати про безпеку та здоров'я
своїх екіпажів, які нині перебувають в епіцентрах епідемії.
Їхні відрядження організовують так, аби пілоти ні з ким не контактували.
Авіакомпанія виконує національні правила карантину,
і коли екіпажі повертаються до України, їх відправляють на обов'язкову обсервацію.
За даними авіакомпанії, поки в них жодного хворого.
Українські "Мрія" та "Руслан" завжди вабили охочих
сфотографуватися на фоні гігантських літаків.
Нині ж залізних птахів зустрічають поодинокі військові, офіційні особи, міністри.
Пілоти з ними не спілкуються.
Лише бачать репортажі на місцевих телеканалах, де дякують їм і Україні.
Є свої герої. І це насамперед люди…
Ті, які працюють у супермаркетах, розставляючи продукти на полиці.
Медики, які іноді, не маючи повного захисту, борються за життя наших громадян.
А є і такі колеги з "антонівських" авіаліній,
які летять у найскладніші точки планети,
де розповсюджується коронавірус, і роблять свою справу.
Командир Ружанський та штурман Кошицький у небі вже понад сорок років,
пережили вже  різні ситуації і героями себе не вважають.
Кажуть, що для них справжні герої - це медики.
Раді, що теж можуть долучитися до боротьби проти вірусу.
Упораємося! Все привеземо.
Китай поборов цей вірус, ну і, я так думаю, що увесь світ його поборе. А ми допоможемо.
За інформацією концерну "Укроборонпром", куди входить держпідприємство "Антонов",
усі рейси "Русланів" та "Мрії" комерційні,
а частина їх здійснюється за програмою НАТО SALIS, партнером якої є "Антонов".
Підприємство співпрацює з НАТО з 2000 року.
Графік польотів українських "Русланів" та "Мрії " розписаний майже до кінця травня.
22 квітня "Мрія" має привезти великий вантаж також і в Україну.